we're about to do something very
dangerous that should not be done at
home by anyone of any age group we are
going to saber a bottle of champagne
you've done that before right I want to
make sure the bottle is dry and then you
want to look for the seam in the glass
if you look closely at the bottle you
can find a line
he's a natural natural dancer overload
with Lorelai Oh trust me it goes back to
like Napoleonic times his soldiers had
said wood after battle to celebrate but
the back of their sores on that seam and
then just I have to get the fancy glass
there it is and that's how you do it
this is a pot I'm a cook Greg me so I
have a few of these laying around the
good thing about this is that you can
use it as a cup too
just like that
watch this
I don't think this was a compatible
device your watch is connected to your
phone which is connected to your laptop
which is connected to your desktop which
is connected to your iPad which is
connected to your iPad pro which is
connected to your ability to open a
bottle of champagne you need them more
like little probably some fresh phone
phone here what was the force behind it
but like we'll never be led to the Apple
Store game
you're drinking champagne you're
probably celebrating you probably dress
up a little bit right
she's probably tab dude should buy a
table dance well we recommend as part of
your outfit if you're going to be
drinking champagne
shoes think about it for Savion Glover
all right we need something else don't
we use in tap shoes most people have
this laying around the house it's a
butter knife you want the honors you
know I mean I like butter
I like great like you're buttering your
bread with just butter like butter the
bottle it is right read that my
sourdough will never know boom it's
beautiful your time flat the teacher is
19 I'm the student you don't need me I'm
done
he doesn't need me I'm out of here call
me